c'est plus chaud peut porter toutes les
donnes gps ma tête j'ai pas été assez
clair et pas la bienvenue ici tu n as
les couilles et toute cette vallée
jusqu'à ce que ces chiens galeux sorte
de sa cachette
c'est bishop ta peau c'est pas un tueur
qu'il faut c'est tout un régiment tu
ferais bien de rentrer chez toi pour
voir ça avec ton mari
il est mal en point il vaut pas le coup
des skates avis jane ma vie je décide
seul de ce qu'elle vaut toi t'as plus
rien à dire tu mais de combien d'hommes
on parle
ils étaient une bonne dizaine
des peuples est ravi j'espère que bishop
recrute que des gros c'est vraiment rude
peut-être mais je risque ma vie pour toi
et ton [ __ ] de marie tu sais rien de
lui tu devrais pas dire ça si sûr c'est
que c'est un criminel
il vaut 2000 dollars je suis prêt à
doubler cette somme si vous réussissez à
ramener amende ni si c'est sûr que tu es
bien parti pour le grand saut mon ami je
te tuerais ça vous fait assez dynamite
et de munitions pour recommencer une
guerre
très bien entendu ton histoire
histoire j'étais un criminel mais je ne
ferai pas une enfant j'ai maintenant
c'est malheureux mais si je te le dis
qu'est-ce qui me restent mois dis moi où
est